哈喽，
今天咱们要来聊一聊最高人民法院、
民政部还有全国妇联一起发布的几个跟彩礼有关的典型的案例，
希望给大家伙在彩礼纠纷这件事情上有一定的借鉴价值。
我们先来看第一个案例，
这个男子双方是在2020年9月的时候就领证结婚了，
男方家里在当地是低收入家庭，
不过为了能够把这个媳妇儿娶进门，
硬是给了女方十八万八的彩礼，
在当地来讲，
这个彩礼数额有点高，
女方嫁过来半年多吧，
2021年4月有过一次初始妊娠，
就是俗称的流产。
至于为什么流产，
这个案例里面没有说清楚，
咱也不知道是没有办法生，
还是女方自己选择不生，
我觉得这个是一个很关键的点。
后来这两人就闹矛盾了，
2022年的2月份的时候，
男方就起诉离婚，
还让女方把188000的彩礼全部还回来，
从领证到起诉离婚也就一年零七个月的样子，
最后法院是怎么判决的呢？
法院觉得这两人婚前也没有什么深刻的了解，
婚后也没有建立起来生活的感情，
所以这个婚姻没有办法继续了，
就准于离婚了。
再看看当地的生活水平和男方的家庭状况，
这188000的彩礼确实数额过高。
给男方的家庭带来了过重的负担，
综合考虑，
双方共同生活的时间不长，
一年多嘛，
然后女方有过一次流产这个事儿，
为了化解矛盾，
就说女方要返还56400块钱的彩礼钱，
这个跟十八万八比起来的话，
差不多是30%的返还。
这个案例有什么典型的意义呢？
咱得明白啊，
彩礼是以结婚为目的，
按照习俗给付的财物。
在咱们国家，
婚嫁这一块，
彩礼包含着对婚姻的期盼和祝福，
但是如果给了彩礼，
超出了自己的负担能力，
成为高额彩礼，
那就跑偏了，
背离了爱情和婚姻，
那么把婚姻弄得好像跟交易似的，
就不但会让彩礼的给付方有很强的经济压力，
也会影响着家庭和谐和稳定，
不利于弘扬社会良好的风气。
从2021年开始，
中央一号文件连着三年都在提治理高额才艺的事儿，
要遏制这样的陋习，
培养新的文明风尚。
在这个案例里面，
一般来说，
如果双方领了证还一起生活了，
离婚的时候想要返还彩礼，
法院是不支持的，
因为给付彩礼的人除了想要领证，
更重要的是想要两个人长期的生活在。
一起过日子，
所以共同生活时间的长短，
那是确定彩礼该不该返还，
该返还多少的一个重要的因素。
在这个案件里面，
这俩人一起生活一年多，
给彩礼的目的还没有完全的实现啊，
大家不知道这个长期到底是多长时间，
反正从司法时间的经验来看，
起码得两年或者两年以上才能算是长期生活的状态。
在这个案子里面，
男方没有明显的过错，
没有家暴，
没有出轨，
没有嫖娼这些乱七八糟的错误，
关键是跟男方的经济家庭比起来，
这个彩礼的数额过高，
比如说男方家里穷的叮当响，
这个彩礼可能是男方家庭年收入的好多倍，
男方为了凑这个彩礼，
还得找亲戚朋友去借钱，
去银行去贷款，
在这种情况下，
就很容易用这个理由让女方退彩礼。
不过咱们得考虑女方在这场婚姻里面经历了一次流产，
这对女方的身体也有损害，
所以法院最后是判退30%的彩礼，
这样两边的利益都能得到一个平衡。
这个典型案例公布出来，
也是为了提倡文明节俭的婚礼习俗。
有句话说得好，
让婚姻始于爱，
让彩礼归于礼。
我们再来看第二个案例，
在男女双方是2018年。
11月经人介绍认识了，
三个月后就一起住了，
一年多后生了个儿子，
儿子30岁多的时候，
两人举办了结婚的仪式，
但是到现在都没有去领结婚证。
这个过程中，
男方给了女方16万的彩礼，
等到孩子2岁多的时候，
两人产生争论，
结束了同居关系，
男方就起诉女方，
要求女方返还80%的彩礼，
也就是十二万八。
后来法院审理觉得这两人已经按照习俗办了婚礼，
还生了一个孩子，
孩子已经两岁了。
法院就觉得两人在一起生活的时候，
尤其是生娃养娃的时候，
肯定有日常性的消费支出，
养孩子的费用，
如果以夫妻名义生活在一起，
生儿育女，
孩子都两岁了还可以退彩礼，
那对女方是不是太不公平了？
所以这个案子最后是驳回了男方的诉讼请求。
这个案子明确提出了一个观点，
那就是最高人民法院关于适用中华人民共和国民法典婚姻家庭编的解释1第5条说，
没办结婚证手续要求返还彩礼的，
这里只应当适用于既没有办结婚证手续，
又没有共同生活的情况，
就应该全部退彩礼。
但是只要在一起共同生活了，
虽然没有领证，
不是法律上的夫妻关系，
可是审理彩礼返还纠纷的时候，
不能忽略共同生活这个事实。
共同生活在彩礼案件里面是超级重要的一个考察点。
共同生活这件事儿，
它不但承载着给付彩礼一方的重要目的，
还对女方的身心健康有一定的影响，
特别是生了孩子这种情况，
要是因为没有领证就让全部返还彩礼，
那就太不公平了，
不利于保护妇女的合法权益。
这个案子里面，
这俩人虽然没有领证，
但是他按照当地的习俗办婚礼，
以夫妻的名义在一起生活了3年多，
快4年，
还生了一个孩子，
孩子已经满2岁了，
所以判决符合当地的风俗，
平衡了各方的利益，
也体现了对妇女权益的保护。
一份彩礼都不用退，
好了，
今天的两个案例就说到这里了，
第一个案例是领了证，
在共同生活时间短，
离婚的时候，
根据共同生活的时间，
有没有孩子的这些情况，
对数额较高的彩礼酌定返还了。
关键是男方家里穷，
彩礼在当地算高的，
经过时间短，
男方没有过错，
女方有过一次流产，
综合这几项，
最后退了30%。
第二个案例是没有领证，
但是共同生活时间比较长，
三四年呢，
还是。
问孩子，
孩子已经满2周岁了，
一般情况下他就不支持退彩礼了，
特别是彩礼在当地数额不算高的，
弥补男方家庭也能承受的时候，
那就一分不用退。